hello and welcome to the first episode
of aldente creepypasta horror stories
cooked to perfection with a splash of
red sauce
my name is CZ and i will be your server
this episode before I get into the menu
let me tell you a little bit about this
series al dente creepypasta will feature
quality narrations of completely
original stories that you won't find
anywhere else each tale will be
presented with chill inducing sound
design and original music compositions
for a production value that will go
unparalleled on YouTube these stories
are longer than what you're used to on
si Z's world
feel free to listen to them at work
while getting stuff done around the
house in the car or if you're feeling
brave as you fall asleep at nights
today you'll be getting a three-course
meal with a theme of Halloween horror
stories I know you're hungry so let's
dig right in one the forbidden house
this is a story that happened several
years back when trick-or-treating with
my friend Alex
my older brother Jon and his friend Evan
every neighborhood has that one house
that nobody ever wants to trick-or-treat
at whether it be because of bad candy
mean owners a dentist house fear or
otherwise in this case our parents had
told us that we could go off on our own
this year as long as we stayed together
and agreed not to go to that house I was
in fourth grade that year and the idea
of getting to go off on our own was
exciting to me at the time
so naturally I agreed when Alex and Evan
got to our house we waited around and
answered the door for a while trying to
scare some of the younger
trick-or-treaters eventually after our
parents took our baby sister to some of
the houses we grabbed her pillowcases
and set off to get some candy we lived
in a pretty safe neighborhood so it was
common for kids our age or even younger
to go out alone looking back now I had
grown up in a borderline pretentious
suburban neighborhood
the type of community you'd see in
movies like Donnie Darko or American
Beauty almost everyone in our
neighborhood had decorations and those
who didn't had these decorative wooden
ghosts nailed to the side of their
mailbox they were more of a cutesy
decoration than scary but they did give
a nice uniformity to all the houses in
the neighborhood it was starting to get
dark when we reached the house that our
parents told us not to go to this wasn't
your stereotypical dark manner at the
end of the block but it was a little
further away from the street than many
of the other houses and sort of tucked
back behind some trees I suggested that
we go back to our house to dump whatever
candy we had off before hitting up
another neighborhood but John and the
others were curious to see what the big
deal was about the dark house I'll have
to admit I was quite curious about why
my parents didn't want us going over
there and it did seem harmless enough so
I figured they would have no way of
knowing if we quickly hid this house the
driveway was long and dark and there was
no light coming from the house
whatsoever this was one of those houses
where the front door was more on the
side of the house with a curved path
leading back up to the front I noticed
that this house did not have the wood
Ghost attached to the mailbox like every
other house in the neighborhood and as
we walked up I was starting to get a
little nervous and I told John that I
didn't think anyone was home but he
thought I was just trying to chicken out
and continue down anyways we reached the
house and John loudly bangs on the door
it was taking forever and I was fairly
convinced that the guy wasn't home or
didn't want to deal with
trick-or-treaters just when I was ready
to turn and give up on the house we all
fell silent as the sound of footsteps
could be heard on the other side of the
door while this did make me nervous I
was also excited to see what was on the
other side of the door that made my
parents so worried about this house so I
stepped back a little bit giving myself
some room to run if
the door open revealing an older man
with a cane this immediately alleviated
some of my anxiety as it would be pretty
easy to run if need be the man was
actually very nice and told us that we
were the first visitors of the night and
that he didn't expect to see many
trick-or-treaters this year apparently
he lived alone and had had some kind of
dispute with the neighborhood homeowners
association over the upkeep of his
property so many of the adults were
trying to get back at him by excluding
him from all the neighborhood
festivities he seemed like such a nice
guy and we actually felt pretty bad for
him we all wished him a happy Halloween
before going on our way I had felt silly
about being nervous about visiting this
house at least that's how I felt before
what happened next
as we walk down the path back to the
street side of the house I happened to
glance at the upstairs window and saw a
man in a black hood peeking out from
behind the window frame as soon as I
made eye contact with him
he moved back out of sight my stomach
immediately dropped as the man had just
said that he lived alone I bolted as I
told the guys to run but John and Evans
seemed convinced that I was just being a
baby I tried to quickly tell them that
there was a man in the window but I
don't think they believed me however
John being the older of the two of us
was supposed to keep an eye on me so
when I made a mad dash back towards our
house he effectively gave chase I knew
in the back of my mind that although the
old man may not have been mobile that
this other guy was most likely a fully
capable adult who probably would be able
to catch us so I didn't stop until I was
inside the door my parents had just
returned from taking my sister out for a
round of the neighborhood and they could
immediately see that there was something
wrong not wanting to get in trouble for
disobeying them I lied and told them
that we were walking by the house when I
saw a man in black climbing through the
window of the old man's house and that
he had seen us catching him in the act
apparently this was a pretty good cover
story as it was enough to get my mom to
call the cops and four of us locked
inside the house for the rest of the
night
the other guys were pretty bummed out to
have our trick-or-treating cut short and
we decided we'd watch a movie and begin
trade negotiations on our candy a little
early this year I had a hard time paying
attention to the movie and kept looking
back to the window thinking about what
the possibility might be that the guy
tracked us here not much later that
night we learned that the police had
searched the old man's house and found a
19-year old man hiding in the closet
with a knife
apparently the intruder had no idea who
lived there and decided to break in
after seeing the house was completely
dark and being avoided by
trick-or-treaters on Halloween night the
old man was also unharmed
but years later I still shudder to think
about what could have gone down that
night what if I had seen the intruder on
the way up to the house before learning
that the old man lived alone what if the
intruder had been on the first floor and
decided to give chase to us but what
chills me the most is what would have
happened to that nice old man if we had
never trick-or-treated at his house to
the Scarecrow Oh always remember seventh
grade Halloween as one of the last good
innocent years of trick-or-treating with
my friends before the paradigm shift to
haunted houses parties [ __ ] costumes
boys and alcohol
I'll also remember it though for one
other reason that I haven't been able to
erase her my mind since that night I
remember that day it was Friday so
almost everyone wore their costumes to
school
Jane Margaret and I had decided to go as
the Powerpuff Girls even though the show
was a long since irrelevant at the time
Jane was bubbles Margaret went as
Buttercup and I being the only one
without the correct hair color or a red
wick to become blossom during homeroom
everyone showing off their costumes one
of our guy friends Chris was the only
one who didn't wear his costume to
school Chris was one of the more popular
guys that we knew so I found it kind of
strange that he hadn't dressed up when
Margaret asked him why he didn't win her
costume he just told us that we'd have
to stop by his place tonight if we
wanted to see his costume we got the
idea that whatever he was wearing was
obviously too graphic to be brought to
school and made plans to swing by and
check it out sometime that evening by
the time I made it to Chris's house it
was starting to get pretty late and I
figured we had about an hour so of
trick-or-treating left before we had to
call it a night
we were a bigger group of girls now
probably six or seven of us all in
costume his house didn't seem to have
much in terms of decoration just a few
of those Halloween store cobwebs you see
on the porch and a scarecrow sitting on
the bench near the front door someone
rang the bell and Chris's mom showed up
just in regular clothes with a witch hat
which I'm pretty sure she wore on
multiple years as a picked out candy
marker asked if Chris was home but his
mom told us that he had gone out to
scare some trick-or-treaters with a
couple friends I was the last one in
line to take a piece of candy so I
thanked her and we went on our way as I
walked back to the sidewalk
I felt something behind me but tug on my
wig pulling it off my head a little bit
I looked back
and I saw the Scarecrow mr. just a
couple inches behind me a couple of the
girls that out screams as well when they
turned around and noticed the Scarecrow
had moved from the bench and snuck up
behind us
Margaret seemed to be the first one to
come to realization that it was Chris
who had dressed up and waited for us
inside the Scarecrow when Jane asked how
long he had to wait there he didn't say
anything and just stared at us which
admittedly made me a little bit
uncomfortable but I tried not to show it
not wanting to give the Nonna prankster
any satisfaction I guess he didn't want
to break character because even as we
invited him to come trick-or-treat out a
few more houses he remained silent for
the rest of the time Jane and I poked
fun at him trying too hard to be mr.
creepy mysterious trying to get him to
crack or laugh or something but it
didn't work he just followed us from
house to house for another block or so
until we all decided to go back to my
house and hang out for a while he would
occasionally tug on my wig but I tried
not to react because I knew that was
exactly what he wanted so we stayed up
late seeing as how tomorrow is a
Saturday and we could sleep in as long
as we wanted one of the girls went home
but the rest of us had been Chris stayed
up to watch a scary movie which ended up
not being so scary Chris didn't even
seemed to want to watch the movie he
just stared at us the entire time I knew
he was just trying to freak me out so I
ignored him and tried to pay attention
to the movie I was bored I fell asleep
about 20 minutes in when I woke up it
was around 3:00 in the morning and
everyone else passed out on the couch
Chris however was gone I figured that he
wouldn't be able to mess with us anymore
and walked home when we got back to
school on Monday we confronted Chris
that is all stunts on Halloween he got
this confused expression on his face and
told us that his family didn't own a
scarecrow or a scarecrow costume
that he had been out all evening to be
treating with his friends he even showed
us a picture of his group with him
wearing at Jeff the killer costume he
seemed to have no idea what we were
talking about when we brought up this
care crew a couple of his friends even
served as his alibis saying that they
were with Chris the entire night to this
day I don't know if this is an elaborate
prank or if some stranger actually
followed us around all night but what
really bothers me most to think about is
the possibility that this guy came into
my house and after all of us were asleep
left without taking anything or saying a
word I've never seen that particular
scarecrow costume again and to this day
I've never gotten Chris to admit that he
was behind it
number three costume shop
I know Halloween is supposed to be a
spooky holiday but my first Halloween
experience left me with scars and
nightmares for years to come
having moved to the USA when I was 17 I
had never actually celebrated Halloween
before because it wasn't even a known
holiday in my home country a few years
later when I got my first job as a
computer consultant I wanted to do
whatever I could to get ahead and move
up in the company when my boss mentioned
that there would be a company Halloween
party I saw this as an opportunity to
impress by finding the best costume in
the office I wanted to avoid the cheap
quality of pop-up Halloween stores so I
found a nice costume rental shop with
some supposedly higher quality wares I
headed over there after staying late at
work that night it was pretty far away
in the middle of nowhere but I was
hoping it would be worth the extra miles
I got in there about an hour before
clothes but to my surprise the place was
pretty much empty
there was only one customer in there
despite the fact that we were already
pretty late into October I wasn't
exactly sure what I wanted to go as so
the owner of the store helped me pick
out several costumes that I was
interested in and let me into the
changing room to see how they all looked
on me I started to get undressed when I
heard the door chime signaling that
someone was entering or leaving this was
a fairly large shop but it was small
enough that I could hear what was going
on in the front from where I was which
is why my heart sank when I heard this I
then hear a horrified scream which I
think was coming from the other customer
that was in the store with me I said
back to the wall now that was a
different voice as far as I could tell
there were at least two men who were
operating this the entire store was
suddenly silent
that's when I heard what seemed like the
loudest gunshot I've ever heard I
literally had to cover my own mouth to
prevent myself from gasping or screaming
and tried to stay as quiet as possible
I heard the familiar sound of a cash
register opening and it was quiet for a
few moments as I could only hear people
shuffling around which I assumed was the
guy hopping over the counter and
unloading the register into a bag or
something after that there was a quieter
exchange between the first robber and
the owner of the store I couldn't hear
it very clearly but from what I could
gather the robber had asked to be taken
to the vault or something like that it
seemed like the accomplice stayed back
with the other customer and the lights
in the entire store had been turned off
possibly to make it look like they were
closed from the outside I thought about
calling the police but I was afraid that
they would hear me given how quiet it
was and how well sound seemed to travel
in the store my hands were shaking as I
tried texting my roommate to ask him to
send help
but I was cut short when I heard two
pairs of footsteps headed in my
direction the sent me into a panic since
I had left a couple of items on the
floor the door to the dressing room was
a thin swinging door with diagonal
upward-facing slots so that I could see
out to the ceiling but someone on the
outside would only be able to see part
of the floor if they tried to peek in as
quickly and quietly as possible I
gathered up everything from the floor
and moved it onto the bench I picked my
feet up onto the bench and tried to
squeeze myself into the corner there is
a small slot under the door not enough
to fit through but enough that you could
see if someone's feet were on the ground
from the other side I was able to see
two pairs of shoes walk right past my
door while I tried not to breathe they
seemed to go into the back somewhere so
I decided to finish my text message and
hope that my roommate would notice and
contact the police for me this is before
I knew that some call centers allow you
to send a text message to 911 one
directly which is now recommended for
situations that are too dangerous to
talk I was so nervous as I waited for
about 15 minutes while the owner and the
robber were somewhere in the back at no
point during this experience was I ever
comfortable but there was a point where
I kind of got used to the situation
my heart rate seemed to slow down a
little bit then out of nowhere this came
from the back of the store because this
happened after several minutes of
complete silence I nearly had a heart
attack when it happened and fell off the
bench I was praying that the other
robber didn't hear that because I was
convinced that the store owner was dead
and I would be next if they found out
about me the robber then walked back
past my changing room i sat there in
shock thinking that I might be the lone
survivor of this crime with any luck but
whatever hope I did have was dashed when
I heard what he said next I didn't dare
move a muscle as I heard the two men
methodically taking apart at the rest of
the store I thought back to when the
store owner had let me into the changing
room how he had unlocked the door to let
me go in I thought maybe just maybe that
they would assume that the doors are
locked at all times and leave it be but
again my head started burning when I saw
a figure standing right outside my door
through the slots trying to peek inside
he tried the door handle and started
loudly banging on the door he then
starts to throwing himself against the
door like a madman literally see the
door breaking off its hinges before my
eyes it's not gonna take much more abuse
and finally
I hear the guy yell out let's go and
they both run for the exit the rest of
the night was pretty much a blur to me I
remember the police arriving me being
marched back through the store seeing
police and ambulance lights seeing the
bloody mess made along the wall probably
from that first customer I was taken in
for questioning I probably wasn't very
helpful considering that I never saw
their faces as far as I know neither of
them were ever caught it's pretty
obvious to me why they decided to steal
from a small costume shop just before
Halloween but I still wonder why they
felt the need to kill especially someone
in my position who didn't even see their
faces
I've had many nightmares about the
incident and I struggled to get the idea
out of my head ever since I've tried
talking to therapists and friends about
the situation and people have come up
with their own theories the best and
probably most haunting theory that I've
heard so far came from a witness who
worked at a nearby restaurant and was
getting off his shift around the time
that I was in the costume store that
night after hearing about what happened
in the news he theorized that the two
criminals didn't do it for the money
but rather did it for the thrill I don't
know if there's any truth to this but he
said he noticed two men in tuxedos walk
into the shop wearing animal masks
thanks for sticking around for our very
first aldente creepypasta special thanks
to my two collaborators on this video
sinister stories was the narrator of the
scarecrow she has her own creepypasta
channel where she covers some fan
favorites so send some support her way
the music in this episode was created by
a very small youtuber but also one of my
favorites by the name of OST maker if
you love really high quality scores and
music compositions go check out the
channel and subscribe because OST maker
deserves a lot more recognition right
now that's gonna do it for today it
looks like your bill comes out to 10
dollars and 31 cents but if you like
this video right now I can waive that
fee and you can have everything you just
listen to absolutely free remember to
subscribe to see ZZZ world from new
Horrors every other week and I'll see
you in the next one
assuming we both survive
you